so in you have this idea for a comedy
feature you said that you wrestle with
in your head for like what five years
yeah and so somehow then you obtain this
camera package and what happens in this
idea finally said to yourself I think
this is time to do it or yeah I mean it
was uh oh we were very lucky we Joe was
around when i first wrote the initial
script and if i make it go he said we
need to shoot this and you know it was a
short non several world non non sequitur
but we end up trying to make it many
many years ago and within like 30
seconds realized we were in over our
head we didn't have the experience we
actually no idea what we were doing so
we stopped immediately yeah we pretty
much yeah it was yeah sushi after do
shots be rude it was done that connect
so we went back to the drawing board and
I wrote many things many other things
for a while and then Joe called me up
one day and he was like you know you
really should consider shooting a movie
again or we should try to shoot that
movie again he's like I think we're
ready and I was like funny you say that
because I was thinking the same thing
and three months later we were in
pre-production yeah so it had happened
pretty quickly and Joe he runs a
creative media company so he had all the
joe hots media he had all the equipment
so there were very few things that we
needed additionally so we were very
fortunate in that in that regard we had
just can't just enough gear to cover the
bases you know definitely nothing fancy
at that time so and we had mushiya we
had a couple friends like machine
certain tracks yeah we had to build a
camera slider friend Tim engineered this
camera slide of course it was eight feet
long so we can do long slow shouts
unfortunately a couple of the scenes
that we cut we're seeing that more of
that was featured in yeah but it was a
great
yeah they're like other like we had to
be built like LED light panels and stuff
and then ultimately didn't play so well
yeah but um how huge natural light for
the majority of the film but yeah
anything that we didn't have we had
virtually no money we either built or
just figured out another way around it
oh I'd love to hear how you built
facebook I just want to go back to that
initial start you said you were what two
days in the first time around man we
were about a half an hour and a half am
sorry what happened like what what how
much pre-planning did you do no no no me
not we woke up and decided to start
Monday dad day okay I mean I had written
the script and it was completely
unrealistic it was it was it was idiotic
of me to think that it was a reasonable
script to shoot i wrote in two weeks i
had never written anything and i'm like
here we go shoot this thing and
foolishly Joey she was like all right
let's do it and I mean even more foolish
I was like all right Alex I mom n as
well and within again within less than
30 minutes of it were it was within the
first two shots really there's no this
is this is beyond our our ability so um
I mean Joe and the years from the
beginning until when we shot it Joe
worked he has this great a media company
and just grew as a photographer and as
an artist and I just worked on my
writing and the travel all over the
place and then when we finally had that
phone call again two years ago a little
over two years ago we decided then we
should take another shot at actually
making a full feature because we'd shot
we've shot about ten shorts but I mean
the type of shorts they're more like
sketches we're going to do you know five
in a day or there's something or yeah
five and one day
and then someone was improv some of it
was written yeah so we just were trying
different things out and then thought we
were ready to at least take a stab at a
future and this is what we ended up with
so if you were going to go back to those
days and give advice to let's say you're
having herself mm-hmm what would you say
I'd say you have a lot to learn okay do
some pre production e sempre for this
yeah i mean that's the only way we were
able to the only way we were able to do
what we did with this film the was one
of course the relationship and the
community helped out but more
importantly the the pre-production we
put a lot of time into pre-production
because we knew we had no money and we
knew we were going to try to shoot the
film we had we had 14 days and we
actually shot at an eight so we knew we
had no time and we knew we were shooting
it at a time and at the end of fall were
snow in Wisconsin was looming at any
moment so there was room for very few
mistakes so every a lot of almost all
the time went into pre-production until
obviously distribution comes along and
that sort of cripples everything for a
project like this but um but yeah I mean
I would say the biggest advice if you're
in LA I would say head over to film
independent filming and pendants
incredible they have just an infinite
amount of resources you can utilize I
recently came a member and just reading
through what they have to offer I sort
of take myself nass thinking man how did
I not come across this earlier but I
would I mean for someone like me I
didn't go to film school I'm yesterday's
history in college and then decided i
want to write so I had to item I read a
lot of books and wrote for a lot of
years just practicing I mean but I'm not
very good
you know I mean it took I've got to work
pretty hard at so I'm sure other people
are better or maybe pick things up a
little more quickly but I would say you
have to do your homework and to be very
realistic about what your your goal is
our goal was we have this really fun
script that makes us laugh and that we
enjoyed and that we wanted to challenge
ourselves and try to see what the
outcome was mixed with we wanted
hopefully we wanted this project to be a
stepping stone for further exposure we
have no illusions that this is going to
be something insanely successful an arm
130 success because we did what we
wanted to yeah on the schedule that we
set and we didn't have to do anything we
had no other authority that we had to
adhere to it was basically truly an
independent project yeah truly an engine
project we gotta call the shots oh and
that's what we wanted to do especially
for a film that l me once you see the
filaments it's uh I mean it's an oddball
it's an oddball comedy and it's sort of
so it's a little ridiculous
you